- All right, guys, so my jobs here
is to basically make a
bunch of viral videos,
and I'm trying to come
up with a video idea.
Recently, Sarah, right over there--
- What?
- She shined foil.
And it got like seven
million views, it was insane.
So, I've been doing some research,
and I found that people have
been making dirt balls for awhile.
They've been shining dirt,
it looks pretty cool,
so let's go shine some balls.
(playful music)
This video shouldn't be too hard,
because basically, I
mean, all I need is dirt.
Let's go get some dirt.
(playful music)
(car horns beeping)
I don't know where to
find dirt in New York.
Got dirt, I found dirt, I found dirt.
Ow, this dirt is more like cement, so.
Damn it!
I got an idea, we're
gonna go to Central Park.
They've got a lot of dirt there.
(heroic music)
Why are you spinning?
You can't just spin around,
you gotta spin around me.
So, before I go to Central Park,
I need to get some stuff
from a hardware store.
I'm gonna get a shovel
and a bucket for my dirt.
We got a bucket, got my shovel.
And some sandpaper, so I
can polish my dirty balls.
What (laughs)?
And some sandpaper so
I can polish my balls.
(laughs) No.
Some sandpaper so that I can sand my--
Not sand.
And some sandpaper so
I can polish my dirty--
I seriously can't say it.
You think they have
something that I could buy,
like an outfit, so I don't
get my clothes dirty.
(adventurous music)
Okay, so I made it to Central Park.
Coming to get some dirt.
(playful music)
Oh, my God, it's so hot in this.
All right, so I got all my dirt.
Time to go back to the office,
and make these dirt balls.
(playful music)
All right, welcome to my kitchen.
This is where we're gonna
be polishing the dirt balls.
It's gonna be super simple.
I got my bowl and a little bit of dirt.
And then, I'm gonna add
a little bit of water,
so I can turn it into a ball.
And then, I'm gonna sandpaper it,
so that it can become shiny, let's do it.
It feels pretty dry, it's
like kind of flaking on me.
So, I'm gonna add a little bit of water.
Make sure the water's nice
and like, a little bit cold.
(chuckles) I'm just
making this up as I go.
You're gonna pour it in there.
Nice like you're just
watering plants, super easy.
My advice was eyeball the water.
I already poured way too much water,
because well.
Wow, okay, okay, so it's too wet,
I'm gonna add some more dirt to it.
There we go, now it feels good.
Right now, this ball's
a little bit too wet.
So, I'm gonna dry it, we're
gonna put it in the microwave,
and it should be good.
All right, where's the microwave?
Where are the microwaves?
I'm just eyeballing this,
I don't really know what I'm doing.
But it's a dirt ball, how hard can it be?
(microwave whirring)
Dude, it's actually really hot.
Have you ever felt hot dirt before?
(laughs)
It's steaming.
Okay, so here is the dried dirt ball.
It actually looks pretty good.
But it still needs to get sanded.
I got all the liquid out of it,
but I need it to get shiny.
Sarah really, really
sanded that tin foil ball.
(heroic music)
I'm just gonna sand it real hard, ready?
(sandpaper scraping)
(melancholy music)
I have no idea what I'm
doing and I don't know
how I'm gonna finish
this video (chuckles).
(melancholy music)
Okay, so the video's on
the AARP YouTube page.
Let's check it out.
- [Man] You don't wanna have
too much water, obviously.
We're gonna shoot for a
cake batter consistency.
Not too dry, not too wet.
Gently sprinkle some of this dirt over.
The curve of your thumb here
is a good surface to kind
of drag along the surface.
- Okay, all right, I get it.
We're gonna have to go back
to the store (chuckles).
I need something to sift the dirt with.
So, I found this window screen.
And it has double sifting.
And last but not least, got the basin.
First thing you have
to do is sift the dirt.
I'm not gonna pretend
I know why you have to,
but you just have to sift
the dirt, so let's do that.
I'm actually having a good time,
just rubbing dirt (laughs).
Dude, there's a worm, there's
a fricking worm, look.
It's a dead worm.
Now I kind of don't wanna sift anymore.
So, I'm gonna check right now
how much dirt I've sifted,
and if I need to keep sifting.
(chuckles) That's a lot of like--
Look how pretty that
looks, it looks like sand.
Half of the dirt is gonna
be used to make the ball.
And the other half of the
dirt is gonna be dry dirt
that you just sprinkle on the top.
And you make that the
outer layer so it's strong.
Right now, this looks pretty good, right?
He said you wanna get all
the air out of the ball.
So, right now, what you're doing
is you're just kind of compressing it.
Just like the tin foil ball,
you just kind of compress.
This is what it's looking like right now.
It feels pretty heavy, pretty dense.
The next step was to just sprinkle dirt
and rub it in with your thumbs all around.
And they said that they spent
a little bit of time doing that.
It's really gotta be dry for this part.
The only thing I'm worried about
is this dirt was a little bit wet
because it rained in New York yesterday.
And the video we watched,
the guy uses purely dry, dry dirt.
Like, it flakes onto the ball.
I'm gonna leave this
outside, so that it can dry.
I'm gonna try again with dry dirt.
So, I'll see you guys in over 24 hours.
All right, so it's been over 24 hours.
I'm gonna go outside,
and check on the dirt, see if it's dry.
Oh, wow, whoa.
Okay, so the dirt looks like sand now.
It looks nothing like it did yesterday.
We're gonna do steps two and three again.
So, first, you take a little bit of it
and you pour it on the ball.
And then, you rub it in with your hands.
This is a very different sensation
because now I feel like
I'm creating a new layer.
And so, you're gonna have
to do this for awhile.
It's not like you spread
a little bit on the ball
and then, you move on.
You probably have to spend, what?
Like, 20, 30 minutes just rubbing it in,
creating this layer.
And I think I'm gonna go
onto the final step now,
which is just rubbing my hand in the dirt.
Just getting some like, dust residue.
And then, tapping it on the ball.
I think what it does is just kind of
fills in the holes, any tiny little holes,
all the particles will just settle in.
Okay, we got some shoe polish cloth,
and I'm gonna see what happens
if I rub it with shoe polish cloth.
And then, when you reveal it,
when you take the cloth off,
it should be super shiny.
(chuckles) Does that look shiny?
(upbeat music)
That's disgust--
- Is that an avocado?
- It's a dirt ball, I
made this out of dirt.
- Wow, it looks so clean.
- I love it, is this really dirt?
- [Eric] Yeah (chuckles).
- It smells like Central Park.
- Does it really?
- No.
- I would sell it for like, $300.
If you wanna buy it for $300,
I'll also throw in this shirt,
I'll cut a piece of my hair,
and lifetime guarantee
if you call right now.
It's only three payments
9.99, wait, that's not enough.
Three payments of 99.99,
that's hard to say.
99.99 (laughs) 99.99.
I took dirt and I turned it
into something shiny and incredible.
And that means you can just take
anything in this world
and make it beautiful.
That's dirt.
(gentle music)
No, no (laughs).
(fun music)